out of the huddle uh nate mcmillan ran
that for him specifically
and cameron payne just needs to keep
attack
kim has the defender run at him on the
drive charge
with a follow 12 before he hits that one
a moment ago
[Applause]
charge wide open for the three and loads
it up
there's shards for the rebound
pain straight away deep three and
launch and fire cameron payne this is
impressive
i mean i like again i i didn't know that
they had it in him again because if he
goes to him maybe devin and himself can
expand the lead right with his scorn so
it's gonna be interesting to see how he
does it but if this guy keeps doing what
he's doing devon might not get back in
the game
sun's trying to keep him quiet he's got
eight points off the bench
payne looking for another triple and he
will get it
but kelly upgrade just ran around the
court wait wait a way to just take the
air out of the guy
mcconnell had his way in the first half
cameron payne says
uh get back in and then one big
three-point
shot but sean's getting good movement
here well we talked about this earlier
though ej with the sun's leading as
dario sharon's just muscling his way to
the rim